DEVCON ONE.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
IT LOOKS LIKE WE ARE ENDING
TRUMP'S FIRST TERM WHERE IT
BEGAN WITH THE RESISTANCE,
GOVERNMENT LEAKING INCOMPLETE
INFORMATION WITH THE WORST
POSSIBLE SPIN ON IT.
ALL DONE TO ENSNARE THE
PRESIDENT AND ANOTHER MAJOR
COSTLY INVESTIGATION.
AND IN JANUARY 2017 IT WAS COMEY
AND THE DEEP STATE.
SEPTEMBER 2019, IT IS NANCY AND
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER CASE.
>> TODAY, I'M ANNOUNCING THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVE WITH AN
OFFICIAL IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY.
THE PRESIDENT MUST BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
NO ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW.
>> AS OF THIS HOUR, ZERO
REPUBLICANS BUT AT LEAST
179 HOUSE DEMOCRATS ARE IN FAVOR
OF IMPEACHMENT.
AND WHY?
BECAUSE OF WHISTLE-BLOWER
REPORTEDLY CLAIMED THE PRESIDENT
USED WITH WITHDRAWING AID FROM
UKRAINE TO PRESSURE THAT COUNTRY
INTO INVESTIGATING JOE BIDEN AND
HIS SON.
NOW, THE IRONY IS THAT THE CASE
TRUMP WANTED INVESTIGATED
INVOLVED BIDEN HIMSELF
THREATENING TO WITHHOLD ONE
BILLION-DOLLAR AID PACKAGE TO
UKRAINE IF SUPPOSEDLY A CORRUPT
PROSECUTOR WASN'T FIRED.
YET HE BRAGGED ABOUT IT.
WELL THAT PROSECUTOR WAS
INVESTIGATING THE COMPANY ON
WHOSE BOARD OF DIRECTORS, HUNTER
BIDEN SAT.
AND ALSO BOATLOADS OF CASH THEY
PAID HIM.
OH, THAT FACT THAT GLOSSED OVER
BY THEM MOB MEDIA TODAY, THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER HAS NO FIRST-HAND
KNOWLEDGE OF THE PRESIDENT'S
CONVERSATION.
OH, BUT NONE OF THAT MATTERS.
>> THE ACTIONS TO DATE BY THE
PRESIDENT HAVE SERIOUSLY
VIOLATED THE CONSTITUTION.
>> I THINK WHAT IS GOING ON IS
THE PRESIDENT COMMITTED SEVERAL
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSES.
>> THESE HORRIBLE OBVIOUSLY
>> HE IS THE MOST CORRUPT
PRESIDENT IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
>> Laura: NOW, HE HAS, THE
DEMOCRATS IF NOTHING ELSE, THEY
NO DRAMA.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS KICKED
OFF TODAY'S FESTIVITIES POURING
ON THE EMOTION.
>> TODAY, I SAY WITH A HEAVY
HEART, DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE FUTURE OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
AND I'M NOT ALONE.
THE WIND THIS AND SEND AN AIRY
DRUMBEAT HAD THIS EFFECT ALL DAY
LONG ON THE MARKET.
THAT DOUBT PLUNGED 200 POINTS BF
THAT DOUBT PLUNGED 200 POINTS BR
THAT DOUBT PLUNGED 200 POINTS BE
THAT DOUBT PLUNGED 200 POINTS BB
THAT DOUBT PLUNGED 200 POINTS BT
THAT DOUBT PLUNGED 200 POINTS BO
THAT DOUBT PLUNGED 200 POINTS BI
THAT DOUBT PLUNGED 200 POINTS BG
THAT DOUBT PLUNGED 200 POINTS BO
THAT DOUBT PLUNGED 200 POINTS BT
THAT DOUBT PLUNGED 200 POINTS BA
THAT DOUBT PLUNGED 200 POINTS BO
THAT DOUBT PLUNGED 200 POINTS BN
THAT DOUBT PLUNGED 200 POINTS BD
THAT DOUBT PLUNGED 200 POINTS B1
THAT DOUBT PLUNGED 200 POINTS B0
AND RECOVERED AFTER THE
WHITE HOUSE SAID IT WOULD
RELEASE UNREDACTED TRANSCRIPT OF
THE UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT.
BUT THEN IT SUNK BACK BY THE END
OF THE DAY WHEN INVESTORS
ANTICIPATED PELOSI'S BIG
IMPEACHMENT ANNOUNCEMENT.
>> YOU CALLED FOR IMPEACHMENT
HITTING WALL STREET SLAMS AFTER
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN JOHN
LEWIS CALLED TO BEGIN
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT RIGHT NOW.
NANCY PELOSI MEETING BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS WITH THE HOUSE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS WITH SPEAKER
TO HOLD A NEWS CONFERENCE
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING THAT
MEETING.
>> Laura: NOW, THE MOST
SICKENING THING ABOUT THE PHASE,
AND IT IS A PHASE THAT WE ARE
ABOUT TO ENTER, IS THAT HOUSE
DEMOCRATS, THEY KNOW
IMPEACHMENT, THE WHOLE INQUIRY
IS FUTILE.
THE SENATE REPUBLICAN MAJORITY
IS NOT GOING TO VOTE TO CONVICT
THE PRESIDENT AND THE COUNTRY
OVERWHELMINGLY DOES NOT WANT
IMPEACHMENT.
WHAT I THINK MOST PEOPLE DO WANT
IS A CONTINUATION OF WHAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS ALREADY DELIVERED
TO AMERICA.
PEACE AND PROSPERITY.
THE TRUTH IS, DESPITE ALL OF THE
DIRE PREDICTIONS OF A LOOMING
TRUMP RECESSION THAT STARTED AT
THE HAND OF LAST YEAR, THAT
SEEMS HIGHLY UNLIKELY.
SO DEMOCRATS ARE IN AN
UNENVIABLE POSITION GOING INTO
2020.
THAT IS WHY THEY COULD NOT
MENTION THE ECONOMY AT ALL AT
THE LAST DEBATE.
INSTEAD IT WAS ALL HE'S A
RACIST, WHITE NATIONALIST, AND
OTHER PERSONAL ATTACKS.
ANYTHING BUT A SERIOUS
DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW THEY WOULD
OUTPERFORM TRUMP'S ECONOMY.
>> LOW, IT IS JUST A
CONTINUATION OF A WITCH HUNT.
THE WORST IN HISTORY.
THE STRONGEST ECONOMY THAT WE'VE
EVER HAD TO COME WITH THE,
AFRICAN-AMERICAN, ASIAN
AMERICAN, HISPANIC-AMERICAN, THE
LOWEST IN HISTORY, AND THEY WILL
LOSE THE ELECTION.
THEY FIGURE THIS IS THE WAY TO
DO IT.
>> Laura: WHY WITH THE
DEMOCRATS RISK DESTROYING THE
BEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD?
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT HERE.
WIFE RISK HUNDREDS OF
ENTREPRENEURS AND WORKERS WITH
WAGE INCREASES OR FAMILIES WHO
NOW HAVE MORE MONEY IN THEIR
POCKET?
IT'S NOT JUST THE PRESIDENT WITH
A HINT ABOUT THAT.
EARLIER TODAY, NANCY PELOSI
INADVERTENTLY REVEALED THE
REASON.
>> WHAT IS MORE SERIOUS IS THAT
HE CAN'T WIN.
THAT IS VERY SERIOUS TO OUR
COUNTRY.
>> Laura: OH, YES HE CAN WHEN
MET, NANCY.
AND YOU AND THE OVERZEALOUS
RADICALS AND YOUR CAUCUS COULD
VERY WELL BE HELPING HIM SEAL
HIS SECOND TERM.
BEYOND THE GRANDSTANDING,
CULMINATING TODAY, THE DEMOCRATS
PROVE ONCE AGAIN, THEY ARE
INCAPABLE OF PUTTING THE GREATER
GOOD OF THE COUNTRY AHEAD OF
THEIR OWN HATRED OF TRUMP AND
THEIR THIRST TO REGAIN POWER.
PUSHING THE NUCLEAR BUTTON OF
IMPEACHMENT, IT IS AN ADMISSION
THAT THEY ARE NOT COMPETENT.
NOT IN THEIR IDEAS WERE IN THEIR